افاد الجيش الاسرائيلي بتجدد تبدل اطلاق
النار على الحدود مع مصر وكان الجيش افاد
بوقوع حادث امني صباح اليوم ادى الى اصابه
شخصين عند الحدود مع مصر مشيرا الى ان
الامر قيد التحقيق كما دفع الجيش
الاسرائيلي بتعزيزات عسكريه الى نقطه
الحدود بين مصر واسرائيل المتاخمه لمعبرين
تسانا العوجه التجاري ووصل الى المكان
ضباط كبار يشرفون على عمليات التمشيط في
المنطقه وكانت الاذاعه الرسميه
الاسرائيليه افادت ان قوات الامن
الاسرائيليه اشتبكت مع من تقول انهم
مهربون عند الحدود المصريه وان ملابسات
الحادث لا تزال قيد التحقيق ونقلت الاذاعه
عن مصادر امنيه قولها ان الحدث امني خطير
جدا
الجزيره وليد العمري اهلا بك وليد هل
تكشفت ملابسات ما جرى
حتى الان لما تتكشف بالكامل لكن المعلومات
المتوفره والتي تسربت تشير الى انه نحو
السادسه والنصف من صباح هذا اليوم كانت
هناك محاوله لتهريب كميات كبيره من
المخدرات تقدر بنحو مليوني شيكل اسرائيلي
اي نحو 600 الف دولار امريكي تم احباطها
حسب المصادر الامنيه الاسرائيليه التي
نقلت المصادر الاعلاميه الاسرائيليه عن
هذه المعلومات لكن بعد ذلك بقليل وقع
اشتباك مسلح اسفر عن اصابه شخصين يقولون
ولا يحددون ما اذا كانوا من العسكريين ام
لا
وظل الوضع هادئ لبعض الوقت لكن قبل قليل
اعلن الناطق العسكري باسم الجيش
الاسرائيلي ان تبادلا لاطلاق النار قد
تجدد في المنطقه هذه المنطقه تقع بين ما
يعرف بمعبر وهو معبر العوجه من الجانب
المصري كما يسمونه ويقع على بعد نحو 40 كم
شرقه نقطه تلاقي الحدود المصريه
الفلسطينيه الاسرائيليه بين صحراء سيناء
وصحراء النقب ويقع في منطقه قريبه من معبر
نيسان
الذي يمتد شرق يمتد شرقا حتى منطقه
امتد غربا حتى منطقه ايلات على البحر
الاحمر او جنوبا لذلك المعلومات تحفظ
عليها الجيش الاسرائيلي بشكل كبير جدا ولم
يحدد ما اذا كان المصابين من جنوده ام من
العاملين هناك علما ان هذا المعبر المخصص
لادخال او للبضائع التجاريه فقط يكون مغلق
يوم السبت بشكل كامل
ولم يشهر ما اذا الامر فعلا هو مساله
تهريب فقط لكن عندما يوصف مصدر امني كبير
بان الحادث امني وخطير للغايه معنى ذلك ان
المساله ليست مساله تهريب مخدرات فقط
وانما قد تكون تشمل ايضا ته الاسلحه او ما
شابه هذه الحدود معروفه انها هادئه نسبيا
اخر حدث عليها كان قبل نحو عام ونصف العام
عندما وقع اشتباك مع مهربين وتم قتل احدهم
في تلك المنطقه لكن منذ ذلك الحين الى
يومنا هذا لم يشار الى وجود اي توترات او
الى اي عمليات عسكريه او عمليات تهريب
جديده تم ضبطها او تم احباطها لكن مشهوره
هي بعمليات تهريب متواصله وبشكل مكثف الان
هذا الحدث الجديد دفع بالجيش الاسرائيلي
الى ارسال تعزيزات كبيره الى المنطقه
وايضا الى وصول ضباط ومسؤولين عسكريين
كبار يشرفون مباشره على عمليات التمشيط
التي تجري بحثا عن
المسلحين او المهربين المهاجمين لم يشهر
ما هناك تواصل بطبيعه الحال مع الجانب
المصري لكن على ما يبدو ان كل طرف يعمل في
جانبه من الحدود في عمليات البحث والتمشيط
التطور الجديد الذي حصل قبل قليل هو انه
كان هناك تبادل لاطلاق النار مع مسلحين في
تلك المنطقه شكرا لك وليد العمري من رام
الله على كل هذه الاضاحات مدير مكتبنا